tu as compris casimir pour le service
rendu dans sa malle dans l'oeil du post
on m'a derrière et dure bien donc ça on
écrase au total cela a eu un jour julie
ça s'est bien passé votre entraînement
pas bien très bien
tu sais que casimir fera très bientôt un
joueur de tennis tout à fait capable
vraiment c'est vrai qu'on regarde à
attention ce match très bien attention
courroye ah ouais attention mon revers
robert est un
il se défend bien nos formidables et
bien tu sais le sport ça nous avait des
fins non ça m'a l'air bon ce que tu es
en train dé l'histoire tu en aurais pas
une autre pour moi ben non je n'ai plus
d'autres mais on peut partager si tu
veux quand tu veux aussi que dit oui je
veux bien
bon alors à temps oulala c'est pas bien
parfait ce que je fais enfin prenez
toujours ces deux morceaux bon tu donnes
le plus gros morceau à casimir il a
certainement plus cinq mois merci ouais
c'est vraiment très gentil de tout
partager avec moi maintenant c'est
naturel il faut toujours tout partagé et
10 passes tarascon serait-ce alors on
dirait que mais oui mais oui c'est ça le
facteur et monsieur disent 'non' sont en
train de se disputer sa liste incroyable
ça vous êtes un personnage dit et vous
et l'apa minable gaulliste pour renier
ni tête de la caf où le père et mes amis
les amis mes amis je vous en prie que se
passe-t-il
pardonnez moi franchement mais si cet
individu qui me fait sortir de mes gonds
cher ami je suis désolé de vous faire
assister à un échange de mots cv le gars
est ce personnage petit bras faites
attention à ce que vous dites dans le
cas des joues
calmez vous et dites moi si ce parent
vous agissez comme des bébés tous les
deux se réinvente
c'est vrai je reconnais que tout cela
est bien ridicule s'inscrit il est
évident qu un être d'exception
je parle pour moi devrait pouvoir
maîtriser ses nerfs
ben voilà vous êtes calmer maintenant
alors expliquez vous gentiment fait
comme vous voulez
quelque chose malaisie facteur à lésiner
tranquillement rouge c'est simple comme
vous le savez nous sommes partis ce
matin monsieur du snob et moi à la pêche
tout allait bien
le solaire etc ce plan dit c'est là la
mer était calme
bref peu ton idéal pour une journée au
grand air nous avions décidé de déjeuner
sur place avec le produit de notre pêche
malheureusement quand l'heure du repas
est arrivé bas nous n'avons pris qu'un
seul point son pardon je n'ai pris qu'un
seul poisson rouge je ne suis que
c'était votre poisson et voilà c'est ce
qui a provoqué notre dispute
monsieur du snob n'a jamais voulu que
nous partagions son poisson moi c'est
normal puisque été convenu qu'en
démangeait chacun sa propre peine aux
côtés monsieur christophe vous exagérez
un vous auriez dû partager votre poisson
avec le facteur avec vous voyez monsieur
du scope que j'avais raison de vous
traiter d'égoïstes françoise mon avis ce
que vous avez sonné de raconter c'est
que vous y avez apporté une bouteille de
bon vin et vous n'avez pas voulu
partager mais pas me donner un verre
quand un parent dit vous ne vouliez pas
partager le poisson est peut-être qu'il
n'ait pas encore commencé monsieur 19
vous avez mangé tout votre poisson au
nom dans la dispute
il est retombé à la mer et vous facteurs
vous avez vu à vous tout seul une
bouteille de vin en entier mais non elle
est retombée sur un rocher et puis
qu'elle s'est cassé
elle savait juste à votre arrivée vous
étiez en train de parler de l'intérêt
qu'il y a happart a fui la simu z'auriez
duval du poisson tous les deux c'est
vrai vous avez raison juillet à ces voix
sont l'effet de la colère j'étais un peu
nerveux je manquais de quatre mois aussi
monsieur du snob
je vous dois des excuses acceptez-vous
de me serrer la main
on a mis au banc bien volontiers oui eh
ben voilà tout est bien qui finit bien
pas pourquoi
je vois que dans votre colère vous avez
oublié votre matériel de pêche sur les
rochers et qu'en ce moment là marie moot
moot nous mais c'est vrai vous avez
raison julie vanloo prévenez moi je
parle on simule je reviens attendez moi
[Musique]
or on s'abonne nous sommes arrivés juste
à temps le letton porter nos cannes à
pêche
rabat chers amis nous vous devons une
fière chandelle mais voilà qu'est ce qui
se passe de finir bon ben j'ai compris
que l'on devait tout partager alors j'ai
été chercher quelques-uns de mes plus
beaux objets pour les partager avec vous
ni moi l'artiste pour voir julie
j'aurais que donner la moitié de ce beau
dessin mais quasi mais on peut pas
partager a déçu mais si mais si on peut
absolument tout partager voilà bien
pourquoi on soir je te donne la moitié
de ma plus jolies poupées
voilà monsieur je vous donne la moitié
de mon téléphone
voilà pour vous monsieur lisnard j'ai
quelque chose de très beau voilà la
moitié de ma plus belle assiette
un facteur j'ai encore quelque chose
[Musique]
voilà voilà voilà garde aura pour tout
le monde
[Musique]